ILLEGAL CRIMINALS AND THE
SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITIES.
KATIE?
>> THANKS SO MUCH.
JOINING US NOW IS THE MAN AT
THE CENTER OF THE STORY.
ESCONDIDO MAYOR, REPUBLICAN,
AND THE BIERKLY, CALIFORNIA,
MAYOR.
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH.
I SHOULD KNOW THE BERKELEY
MAYOR IS A DEMOCRAT SUPPORTING
THE SANCTUARY POLICIES.
BUT FIRST, I WANT TO GO TO
YOU.
YOU TOOK THE OATH OF OFFICE AS
AN CITIZEN COMING TO THE
COUNTRY AS AN IMMIGRANT.
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW IT PLAYS IN
YOUR DECISION TONIGHT TO BE
AGAINST THE SANCTUARY LAWS
COMING OUT OF SACRAMENTO.
>> I TOOK THE OATH TWICE,
KATIE.
FIRST, WHEN I BECAME CITIZEN,
IN 1990.
AND THEN SECOND TIME WHEN I
WAS ELECTED COUNCILMAN IN
2004.
AND LAST TIME WHEN I WAS
ELECTED MAYOR IN 2010.
I CAME THIS THIS COUNTRY TO
KEEP MY FAMILY SAFE.
AND I SEE MYSELF HERE FIGHTING
FOR THE SAFETY OF MY FAMILY.
AND THE FAMILIES OF ESCONDIDO.
I HAVE 150,000 OF OUR
RESIDENTS.
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH I.C.E.
HAS WORKED PERFECTLY.
THE I.C.E. AGENT HAVE MADE MY
CASE.
AND WE HAVE DEPORTED OVER
2,000 ILLEGAL CRIMINALS FOR
FROM OUR CITY WITH OUR
COOPERATION WITH I.C.E.
WE FOCUS ON CRIMINALS ONLY.
NOW THE I.C.E. AGENTS ARE ON
THEIR OWN AND IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD, AT
OUR STATIONS PICKING UP
CRIMINALS AND INNOCENT PEOPLE.
AS A RESULT OF OUR COOPERATION
WITH I.C.E. THE CRIME IN
ESCONDIDO WENT DOWN BY 33%.
ESCONDIDO TODAY AS SAFE AS IT
WAS IN 1980.
I WAS ELECTED MAYOR TO UPHOLD
THE CONSTITUTION AND ALSO TO
KEEP MY COMMUNITY SAFE.
THIS RESOLUTION TO FIGHT THE
SANCTUARY LAW IS AT THE CORE
OF MY MISSION.
>> SO I WANT TO GET YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT.
THE MAYOR OF ESCONDIDO IS
SAYING THEY HAD 2,000 CRIMINAL
ALIENS THEY DEPORTED FROM
THEIR COMMUNITY WHICH WOULD BE
ON THE STREET IF SACRAMENTO
HAD ITS WAY BY BANNING LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM WORKING
WITH THE CENTRAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT?
WHY SHOULD 2,000 CRIMINAL
ALIENS STILL BE IN THE
COMMUNITIES?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DEFINE WHAT YOU
MEAN BY "CRIMINAL."
CERTAINLY VIOLATION OF THE
FEDERAL, CIVIL, IMMIGRATION
LAW IS A CRIME.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF A BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM?
IN ESCONDIDO THEY HAVE A RIGHT
TOO TAKE A POSITION ON THE
ISSUES FOR THEIR COMMUNITY BUT
THEY DON'T SPEAK FOR BERKELEY
AND THEY DON'T SPEAK FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE MANY CITIES IN THE
BAY AREA AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT BELIEVE THAT
SANCTUARY POLICIES MAKE
COMMUNITIES SAFER.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN MY CITY, CRIME
HAS GONE DOWN IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
EVEN WITH THE SANCTUARY
POLICY, OUR POLICE ARE STILL
COOPERATING WITH THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
THERE WAS AN OPERATION IN MY
CITY A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
WHERE HOMELAND SECURITY
INVESTIGATIONS ARRESTED AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO WAS
ENGAGED IN DRUG CRIME.
>> THE LOCAL POLICE IN
BERKELEY -- IT'S NICE THAT THE
LOCAL POLICE OF BERKELEY ARE
TRYING TO STOP ILLEGAL
CRIMINAL ALIENS WITH THOSE
CRIMES.
IF YOU WANT GET INTO THAT
GOVERNOR BROWN HAD FIVE
CRIMINAL ALIENS WITH VIOLENT
RECORDS LIKE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, ARMED ROBBERY, THEFT
AND ROBBERY, CARRYING OUT
CRIMES WITH THE HANDGUN.
MAYOR ABED, WHAT IS YOUR
MUNICIPALITIES ALLOWING THESE
CRIMINAL ALIENS TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE INSIDE CALIFORNIA?
BECAUSE THEY CAN JUST DRIVE
DOWN TO WHERE YOU ARE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THERE IS A
BORDER.
>> I THINK THIS IS A RISK THAT
NOT ONLY ESCONDIDO BUT EVERY
CITY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND EVERY STATE IN THE NATION.
THIS MAYOR IS IN DENIAL.
THEY WANT TO GIVE SANCTUARY TO
ILLEGAL CRIMINALS.
GIVING SANCTUARY TO ILLEGAL
CRIMINALS AND GIVING THEM MORE
RIGHTS AND PROTECT THE RIGHTS
MORE THAN THE CITIZENS IS JUST
IMMORAL, IT'S ILLEGAL AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
WE NEED TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE.
SB-52, THE SINK WARE STATE
WILL GIVE -- SANCTUARY STATE
WILL GIVE THE IMMIGRANTS LESS
PROTECTION.
BECAUSE I.C.E. WILL BE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD PICKING UP
EVERYONE.
THIS IS JUST INSANE.
THIS IS IMMORAL.
I CANNOT UNDERSTAND WHO
ANYBODY, WHO ANYBODY WOULD
GIVE THE ILLEGAL CRIMINALS
PROTECTION FROM THE LAW AND
MORE RIGHTS THAN GIVING TO THE
CITIZENS.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
CALIFORNIA IS EMOTIONAL.
GOVERNOR BROWN AND THE MAYOR,
THE PROGRESSIVE MAYORS AND THE
LEGISLATORS HAVE LOST SIGHT OF
DOING THE RIGHT THING.
>> WELL, MAYOR ABED, YOU ARE
NOT ALONE.
I WANT TO PULL UP THIS MAP OF
OTHER CITIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES, COUNTIES WHO
ARE LOOKING AT EITHER PUSHING
BACK AGAINST SACRAMENTO OR
ALREADY HAVE.
THERE IS ALMOST MORE THAN A
DOZEN OF THEM AT THAT POINT.
SO CLEARLY LOCAL COMMUNITIES
ARE LOOKING AT THAT AND SAYING
WE DON'T WANT TO BE PART OF
THE LAWS THAT DON'T ALLOW THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO WORK
WITH THE FEDS.
BUT GOING BACK FOR A MOMENT,
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO
THOSE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
CRIMES OF CRIMINAL ALIENS WHO
ARE ALLOWED TO BE OUT ON THE
STREETS NOW BECAUSE THE NEW
SANCTION WARE -- SANCTUARY
STATE LAWS ALLOW THEM TO
ESCAPE I.C.E. AND RECOMMIT
CRIMES?
>> MY RESPONSE TO THAT IS WE
HAVE UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS
WHO ARE --
>> OKAY, FIRST OF ALL.
WHAT IS AN UNDOCUMENTED
RESIDENT?
THAT IS NOT A THING.
>> SOMEONE UNDOCK
METROPOLITANNED WHO LIVES IN
THE COMMUNITY -- UNDOCUMENTED
WHO LIVES IN THE COMMUNITY.
>> ILLEGAL ALIEN.
>> YOU CAN REFER TO THEM THAT
WAY BUT I CALL THEM
UNDOCUMENTED.
IT TAKES YEARS FOR PEOPLE TO
GET CITIZENSHIP STATUS.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER WE ARE A
NATION OF IMMIGRANTS.
>> THE GUY ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF YOUR SCREEN CAME HERE
LEGALLY.
>> IMMIGRATION REFORM TO FIX
THE PROCESS SO PEOPLE CAN
LEGALLY BECOME CITIZENS.
>> I HAVE TO STOP YOU THERE.
YOU ARE ARGUING THAT THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA THE
MOST GENEROUS COUNTRY IN WORLD
PEOPLE ARE UNABLE TO BECOME
CITIZENS AND STAND UP FOR THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THE MAN WHO IS DEBATING YOU
TONIGHT, MAYOR ABED, DID THAT.
HE DID THAT FOR HIS COUNTRY.
SO FOR YOU TO SAY THAT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET CITIZENSHIP
JUST IS NOT ON PAR WITH THE
FACTS.
MAYOR ABED, DO YOU WANT TO
RESPOND?
>> IT'S OFFENSIVE.
IT'S CLEARLY OFFENSIVE.
THEY ARE GETTING -- MY TWO
DAUGHTERS WENT TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN MARCOS.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS PAY LESS
TUITION IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THEY ARE GIVEN MORE RIGHTS.
NOT ONLY EDUCATIONALLY,